it's great to be joined by former
Maryland governor and former 2016
Democratic presidential candidate martin
O'Malley governor let's just jump in of
the vice presidential debate what did
you think I thought that Tim Kaine from
my perspective did what he needed to do
he defended not only Hillary Clinton and
her vision but he prosecuted Donald
Trump in ways that his opponent really
couldn't defend except to falsely say
Donald Trump had never said these things
I don't know about you David but I
thought it was bizarre
Mike Pence could keep shaking his head
and say that Donald Trump didn't say
things that all of us and seeing him say
on television for the last three or four
months you wonder if they've banned pent
from watching television since he joined
NSYNC it but I I thought I thought Kane
did a very good job and one thing that
he did had never happened before on a
debate stage was he prosecuted the huge
amount of Russian money that's been
going in to Trump enterprises and the
connections if you will that makes
Donald Trump the Willing Duke for the
interests of Vladimir Putin in these
demean I completely agree with your
assessment that Mike Pence didn't defend
the indefensible because it's there's
just absolutely no way so he said oh we
never said that stuff but I'm curious on
your view as someone who's been both a
participant and observer of these
debates for a long time many people
wrote to me saying that on substance of
course Cain absolutely clobbered pence
but that the optics were that pence was
engaging with the camera in a way that
was more pleasing to the audience at
times when pence would just lie Cain
would seem sort of visibly distraught
and jittery and unsure of way to of
where to look these issues do impact a
viewers perception of who does better or
worse don't they well I think that's
fair I mean on substance clearly Tim
came under the debate and onstyle
I can see why people would give it to
pence he's a he's a rather cool
character I served with him in the
National Governors Association yeah
in fact I shared with Tim Kaine as a
neighboring governor but the but I do
think that ultimately I think substance
prevails but I and I think that people
saw Tim Kaine he was more animated than
usual but then again you know what maybe
Democrats need to get a lot more
animated than they've been through the
course of this race so far and maybe
it's good that we see Tim Kaine having
some fight and feistiness and going
after these guys well along those lines
I was super interested in the dynamic in
the debates with Secretary Clinton and
senator Sanders and you during the
Democratic primary and of course there's
there was no question to anybody who
watched that there was no deficit on on
your behalf in terms of an understanding
of the issues in looking back when we
talked about energy and optics and
substance as you sort of Monday Morning
Quarterback your your campaign why do
you think you ultimately didn't connect
with voters in a way that led to more
polling support oh wow do you have time
for a deer we could unpack all of that
let me give you the short non-alcohol
radio version please there was a
tremendous amount of angst anger
profound desire to protest that affected
the entire electorate this year I kept
hearing before I ran for president
people say we need a change we need to
change but I underestimated just how
much people wanted to pull their their
car into the angry lane market and throw
the keys out the window that came to
that desire that sense that our
politicians aren't listening
therefore we need to break the kitchen
table manifested itself in the
Republican Party with the rise of Donald
Trump the first time that a third party
candidate or candidate from outside the
party has taken over the Republican
Party and makes these overtly racist and
fascist appeals that just made his
popularity soar Vice President Gore
described it to me this way
he said that the most revealing
interview he saw was a lifelong democrat
asking why he's voting for Donald Trump
and this blue-collar guy said because my
country's got kima on my country's got
cancer and Donald Trump's just the
chemotherapy we need hard to disqualify
chemotherapy by simply calling it
poisoned repeatedly what people are
looking for and what Hillary Clinton has
to offer are the actions that we can
take together that will complete this
story of America's recovery in such a
way that not only is our country doing
better by creating more jobs but
families are doing better by creating
more income we need to make wages go up
and not down and and that's I believe
the task before Hillary Clinton in this
next debate we certainly had a lot of
people in our primaries that also just
wanted to break the kitchen table but
breaking the kitchen table doesn't put
food on it is that a reference to Bernie
Sanders I mean is that certainly the the
dynamic of the Sanders campaign was yes
damn right people should be angry is
that what sort of you're referring to
yes I am and I think it was as Donald
Trump's as Donald Trump's appeal was
also complicated by racial fears and
fear of the world xenophobia I think
that part of the appeal on the left and
our party was also fueled by Donald
Trump's rise by our failure to debate
him from or to take the debate stage
ourselves as Democrats from June through
October as heroes and a lot of people in
our party but well if we're not going to
have a more contested primary the only
thing left to do is is to protest both
the both the front-running candidate and
also the rise of Donald Trump I think
Bernie Sanders made some really good
points in the primary
they were point that he's been making
for 40 years about income inequality and
he really had that message honed to to a
fine fine tune
this platform has primary Hillary
Clinton took the best ideas the Bernie
Sanders in the fight for on affordable
college but the platform also
incorporates something I advanced
traffic and clean energy grid by 2050 -
the United States of America for the
first time we are advocating in our
party's platform repeal of the death
penalty so our party's contest was one
of ideas and in this year of anger and
protests the ideas what we well we
talked about them analyst the the you
know the hallmark of I think this year
will be people's profound desire to
protest all right we've been speaking
with former Maryland governor and former
2016 Democratic presidential candidate
martin O'Malley thanks so much for
joining us we will take a break and be
back with more right after this